every resort town in the US has a candy
store but one store in his mo Beach
California goes beyond the usual taffy
and caramel apples if hot licks has its
way Americans will be snacking on
everything from caterpillars and
cockroaches to mealworm covered apples
Larry Peterman is a candy man on a
mission
for more than a decade he's been
promoting a valuable food source that
most Americans find revolting in a land
of plenty people resist Larry knows why
from an early age parents teach children
to avoid insects in our culture from the
time that we're really small we're
taught to avoid insects they might bite
you like a mosquito our systems got a
good that's got a good cricket in it but
kids aren't the only ones munching on
bugs
around the world more than 1,400 insect
species show up on menus insect eating
or entomophagy is part of healthy diets
in Asia Africa Australia and Latin
America this trend is anything but new
archeologists have found evidence of it
dating to the earliest humans advocates
of insect eating like to note that it's
environmentally sound producing a pound
of Caterpillar takes a tenth of the
resources needed to produce a pound of
beef
and insects brim with vitamins and
minerals but despite all the benefits
most Americans can't stomach bugs
welcome welcome welcome ever seen unlike
Larry Peterman who celebrates them at
his dinner party gentlemen are the
evening begins with Larry's version of
the classic shrimp cocktail
we're just finished preparing a cricket
cocktail it's a lot like a shrimp
cocktail
Paulie instead of shrimp will use
crickets okay folks there's the first
course now enjoy
while you're enjoying this I'm going
down and get your next course the main
course is a stir fry a special garnish
here we go
dinner is served by Cuba get ready okay
go straight go several courses later
Larry presents his piece de resistance
okay here it is what you've been waiting
for now don't anybody dive it until
everyone to the third please
we call them a Pismo surfer what it is
is a banana with whipped cream and a
really good cockroach on it you don't
have to eat the wings you don't have to
eat the head I did unless you want to do
you know oh you know where this has
just been we could do another one next
week if you like Larry predicts he'll
eventually win people over as we become
more and more insect food oriented our
tastes go Jade and so I see a niche for
somebody that does gourmet insects
could have some snob appeal like people
taste wise I mean this is good with this
bug is good